let's do a tricky one this one I don't
think I was saved so I think this is 13
so they say differentiate so you got two
challenges here number one just
algebraically he's a little more intense
okay though it's ood yeah anything extra
step that you're gonna have to evaluate
but that's fine we're gonna do that it's
not what difficult is just a bit longer
all right so let's start off the
derivative of x squared e to the minus x
squared okay let's have a go
there's product rule here is also
general but it's an easy chain rule
chain rule with is pretty simple
okay so what should we write what's the
first thing
okay so depending where the juvie you -
UV - or the other way around
does matter because it's a so I think on
this side what do we start with where do
we go
yeah okay so we were going UV let's do
that over here there's you what's V - in
this case here's my chain rule comes you
differentiate the inside what is the
derivative of the inside
do yourself a favor and have copious
amounts of brackets around you can
always evaluate things a lot easier with
this wall brackets rather than west so
just so you don't confuse your terms and
absolutely right x squared minus 2x
which there's the outside sorry the
inside what's the dude on the outside
it's either power something was just
when you're differentiate it returns
itself good is the first time and then
you multiply by you - yeah okay pause
for a second I know it's your easy just
to simplify blindly which will simplify
in a second but you always remember
where you want to head okay so this is
the term we're after yeah X cubed in the
best x squared so where is it where is
the excuse it's um it's hiding in here
isn't it we just haven't actually expand
it out right but that's what we're gonna
go out there it's not quite what is it
it's got some extra stuff flying around
okay so just keep that in mind we're
gonna simplify out in a minute okay so
when we go minus 2x cubed x squared plus
2x
okay so beam that what we've got doesn't
have this - to pay at the front okay I
think we were one of the two things
we're gonna make it the subject and then
we want to get rid of that - - okay so
let's do that let's see let's move a
little time so I'm going to get to
execute over here I've got this guy is
positive and I'm subtracting
distributive yeah swapping places really
yeah all right now at this stage on our
other question this was where we
integrated everything okay but we're not
quite there yet I wanna get rid of this
- so I really need to do that into one
line / - here / - the front okay now by
the way you see it - there so I could've
just cancel the - why didn't I do that
can't even see why because I'm always
trying to think of step ahead make
things as simple I can why is actually a
major is to leave that to where it is
what's the next step what am I about to
do I'm about to integrate I know we've
respect to X okay sir excuse me
this guy isn't integrating cuz I know
exactly where it ends up it's gonna end
up there without the little crumb okay
what does this become this is not a
standard integral but I think it's close
enough to one that you can work it out
right where's it going to go well see
that 2x right that 2x is significant
because it's well it's almost the
derivative of the inside function okay
somebody use reverse chain rule here
with an exponential function can you see
that it's almost in the form F - either
than okay the difference is it's not f -
is a it's - f - okay so therefore I mean
I could have 1/2 times 2
they were the edge there but I'd
eventually have to put the suit back
anyway I guess that's why just leave it
there
so I've got 1/2 at the front okay what
happens we integrate this you have -
because of that - right e to the - x
squared plus a constant if you sort of
I'm getting confused - Tim reading right
in signs around the great thing about
any kind of depression question is you
can always check by differentiating you
guys can do differentiation that you
sleep with him tied behind your back so
you can just double check that what we
happened you do the inside function - 2
X comes out the front they use cancel it
you're fine ok great then we've got this
minus DX so integrated
okay yeah because I did both internal at
the same time I've just got one costume
which is nice so I don't have to do
second cuz they okay how are we going
does it look I can't deliver toys what
do I do now
what am I supposed to do where was the
question here do you
it was it was headed toward this
definite integral so I'm really close
quite close all I need to do is change
this from an indefinite agent just when
is right now and slap some upper lower
bounds on it yeah so I put 1 & 2 here
what difference does that make to the
right-hand side okay well I've got its
constant at the front so I'm just gonna
leave him there okay now this is what
I'm going to have to evaluate isn't it
so I'm gonna put some square brackets
now because is this a closet here the
reason is of course is because this is
indefinite right but now that I have
some batteries I don't need to worry
about the constant because I'll just add
and then subtract it it would become me
to do this between your boundaries okay
now I think from memory this question if
you can say there was a need to be used
up so yeah I'm part of I think was
factoring news so let's just quickly do
that and if I took out a factor of minus
e to the minus x squared you end up with
1 plus x squared
yeah
okay now what just evaluate yeah I think
we've done all the hard work it's just
kind of a bit mechanical from here but
let's just go through a furnace age of
it okay
aha times all right what do you get here
actually might as well since that minus
sign is there a Bible
calm down the front dad okay it's just
the close to any ^ - full then it's 1 +
4 there's my up about now we'll do low
amount a to the minus 1 1 plus 1 and
okay oh my god here
I don't like negative indices so I'm
going to get rid of them in the 4th
minus 2 look again
now there's a negative here and they did
here so I might as well turn them around
to on e5 4 less negatives okay I'm gonna
fracture down here it's almost on the
common denominator if I change that to a
4 what do I have to do the numerator I
multiply by e cubed alone so that's
gonna be in cubic top that ok down into
sin denominator I've run out of space
I'll put them in half at the front 2 e
cubed minus 5 save denominator and I
guess I'll just put the 2
okay so what's the diff you a fish I
think it was a long question but none of
the steps are particularly complicated
as long as you're patient with it and
you were careful with you haja bra
you'll be fine okay so today is the
because tomorrow member some of us have
a morning class but on Monday I think
you guys have photos and it takes a
maths lessons so this is our last three
at lesson until Tuesday when I think we
have like three lessons in a row to make
up all right
I didn't pick it so anyway what I'm
going to do is I'm gonna give you your
homework for the next exercise which is
30 day which is just taking the same
ideas but applying it to areas and
Boyer's that's all okay so that's
exercise 30 D on areas and volumes any
questions